[Musique]
alors j'entends par crédulité le fait
que nous avons tendance statistiquement
sur le grand nombre à endosser des
propositions intellectuelle des idées
des représentations du monde qui ne sont
pas toujours sélectionner de façon
optimale
c'est à dire que c'est l'expression non
pas de la bêtise ou de la faiblesse
intellectuelle en général mais
simplement le fait d'accepter des idées
qui vont dans le sens soit de mon désir
ou simplement des pentes naturelles de
mon esprit de mon intuition
[Musique]
alors ça je ne le dirai pas je pense que
la crédulité est vraiment un fait
anthropologique si une négociation
intellectuelle avec le monde la
connaissance en état nos une autre et
selon les conditions sociales évidemment
c'est l'une ou l'autre qui peut plus
facilement s'exprimer salah ben tout
simplement de la façon dont les idées
sont sélectionnés collectivement
socialement mais il est vrai que nous
sommes confrontés non pas donc un
changement anthropologique de l'homme ne
sommes pas plus crédules qu'avant mais
nous avons des conditions sociales qui
facilite l'expression de la crédulité
comme le fait par exemple qu'il y ait
une disponibilité massive de la
formation ya jamais eu autant
d'informations disponibles aujourd'hui
que que n'importe quand dans l'histoire
de l'humanité plus d'informations
publiées depuis le début des années 2000
que depuis l'invention de l'imprimerie
par gutenberg en 2005 et les 150 examine
de données disponibles en 2010 y en
avait huit fois plus à bien cette
disponibilité de l'information qui est
une formidable nouvelle pour l'humanité
bien entendu elle nous permet aussi
d'aller chercher systématiquement
l'information qui va dans le sens de nos
représentations et donc l savone
la pente de la crédulité
[Musique]
ah non ce dont on parle aujourd'hui
n'est pas réellement neuf je ne vous
apprendrai pas qu'il existe toute une
série de textes mythologiques religieux
qui prétendent décrire le monde depuis
fort longtemps donc ce n'est
certainement pas notre époque qui a
inventé l'info ksourou les rumeurs les
légendes urbaines et religions les
superstitions les théories magique et
que sais-je
non notre époque elle donne une
caractéristique particulière je les dis
c'est qu'elle met à disposition beaucoup
d'informations et surtout elle met tous
les points de vue en concurrence que ce
soit le point de vue de la science peut
être concurrencé par celui de la pseudo
science alors qu'auparavant les mondes
sociaux étaient relativement c'est
pareil avec quelques frictions de temps
en temps mais il y avait des régulateurs
de ce marché la caractéristique
d'aujourd'hui c'est que ce marché de
l'information est massivement dérégulé
et que ce qui l'emportent sur ce marché
souvent c'est la motivation des acteurs
ceux qui sont motivés à faire valoir
leur point de vue le rendent plus
visible que les autres et souvent cette
motivation elle n'est pas totalement
décorrélé de la crédulité et d'une façon
générale de motivation idéologique
[Musique]
absolument la bonne nouvelle dans tout
cela c'est que notre cerveau vous savez
c'est un des outils les plus complexes
de l'univers un million de milliards de
connexions dans notre boîte crânienne
alors on en use pas tous de la même
manière manifestement mais il y a des
ressources insoupçonnées dans le cerveau
humain ce que j'appelle le rétro
jugement c'est-à-dire la capacité à
arbitrer nous avons des ressources
d'arbitrage dans notre cerveau très
complexe pas forcément consciemment
traité mais nous pouvons par
apprentissage en effet développé la
pensée critique la pensée méthodique et
je crois que c'est le rôle de
l'éducation nationale de le faire pour
l'instant elle ne le fait pas mais je ne
désespère pas qu'elle tienne compte
disons d avancer tout à fait
significatif de la science dans ce
domaine et ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle ce une raison d'espérer
[Musique]
oui il ya beaucoup de choses à faire la
première chose la plus simple c'est se
demander qu'est ce que j'ai envie de
croire c'est-à-dire vers quoi me porte
mon désir ce que j'ai envie que ça soit
vrai ou faux et généralement déjà cette
prise de conscience du désir qui peut
contaminer le croire c'est un élément
important
à partir de là il ya aussi la
consultation d'argumentaire n'est
meilleur argumentaire qui contredisent
mondésir un allié consultés dont des
forme d'argumentation bien fait et
entendu qui vont dans le sens opposé de
ce que je crois
et puis surtout essayer ça c'est un peu
plus difficile de styliser le
raisonnement que j'entends et que j'ai
envie de croire en quelques formules et
voir si ces formules sont acceptables
d'un point de vue cognitif par exemple
s'il n'y a pas une confusion
systématique entre corrélation et
causalité deux événements qui arrivent
ensemble n'ont pas été forcément causé
l'un par l'autre
est ce que c'est bien une par exemple un
miracle quelque chose de prodigieux ou
est-ce qu'on peut expliquer simplement
par des probabilités
est-ce que je n'ai pas à négliger le
phénomène de régression vers la moyenne
etc etc
mais tous ces éléments demande une
éducation à l'existence des billets
community à l'existence d' erreur de
raisonnement est encore une fois ça
c'est sur le temps long de l'éducation
qu'il faut qu'il faut proposer ça aux
individus qui sont en train de de former
leurs esprits pour qu'ils puissent faire
leur déclaration d'indépendance mental
[Musique]
eh bien je suis concernant l'avenir
d'abord je rappelle que je ne suis pas
tirésias je ne vois pas l'avenir dans
ces rien mais si on me demande de faire
un pari une hypothèse je dirais je
rappellerai effectivement que je suis
optimiste par nature est pessimiste par
observation mais peut-être que mon
observation est elle aussi une croyance
c'est à dire que j'observe des
phénomènes à court terme et que j'ai
tant ça à craindre qu'il se prolonge à
moyen et long termes à tort peut-être
parce que mon maras io na li té est
incarcéré temporellement voyez moi aussi
je suis créé du
[Musique]
d'abord nous nous posons des questions
ce qui est déjà bien ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas où c'est moi ça fait plus de
vingt ans je travaille sur cette
question un j'ai vu émerger évidemment
les sujets j'en ai profité d'avoir le
hasard a fait que l'actualité apporter
mes objets de recherche voilà un peu sur
le devant de la scène
mais déjà on se pose des questions ce
qui est une bonne chose je crois dans ce
genre de domaine surtout parce que
beaucoup de scientifiques qui sont
impliqués que l'intelligence collective
va fonctionner il ya vraiment de travaux
tout à fait remarquable de sciences
sociales computationnelle qui ont déjà
permis de décrire le phénomène les
chambres des coûts etc de façon beaucoup
plus précise et donc que le type de
réponse qu'on peut avoir dépend bien sûr
des questions qu'on pose mais on sait
que les algorithmes sont impliqués la
façon dont l'ordre d'apparition et donc
la régulation du marché de la formation
est impliqué j'ai parlé de régulation
individuelle développement de l'esprit
critique bien entendu les médias
conventionnels doivent se poser toute
une série de questions
il s'en pose de ce point de vue je suis
relativement optimiste là mon pessimisme
vient seulement du fait que le problème
qui est posé à nous est un problème
civilisationnel titanesque multi
variables et je ne sais même pas ce que
je craindrais le plus c'est que nous
soyons condamnés définitivement à la
crédulité en fonction de notre nature
même